rentrez vous le savez antoine d'être
avec son lot de nouveautés pour faire le
point nickel et demi d'euros ont soir
bonsoir
c'est la rédaction est également
aujourd'hui tv 78 c'est notre entrée à
tout le monde beaucoup nouveautés
michael en cette rentrée notamment en
maternelle
alors c'est l'une des grosses nouveautés
de cette rentrée en france et donc dans
l'académie de versailles l'âge de
l'instruction obligatoire passe de six à
trois ans cette mesure va avoir peu
d'impact près de 97% des enfants étaient
déjà scolarisés dès cet âge l'année
dernière dans l'académie versaillaise on
va même un peu plus loin appelant à
maternelle a été créée depuis plusieurs
années pour accueillir les enfants de
moins de 3 ans cette année ils seront
3829 élèves 18 % de plus par rapport à
2016 on écoute la rectrice chanel à
venelles au micro de tv 78 elles
touchent pas un nombre très important
d'élèves mais enfin tout de même elle
permet à ceux qui en est éloigné
d'accéder à l'école et puis surtout elle
s'accompagne d'une réflexion sur l'école
maternelle qui doit amener à acquérir
plus tôt les condamant tôt par exemple
comment on appréhende les nombres les
lettres dès la maternelle et voilà c'est
tout ce que charrie cette réforme de
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans un
autre axe fort pour cette rentrée
l'écologie alors ce n'est pas forcément
une nouveauté mais les gestes
écologiques vont être intensifiées dans
les lieux d'éducation cette année deux
cent soixante treize établissements de
l'académie sont labellisés développement
durable ils luttent généralement contre
le gaspillage alimentaire mais également
en proposant des actions pour protéger
la planète
dès cette rentrée 2010 9 c'est nouveau
des élèves éco délégués sont représentés
dans des conseils de vie collégiennes et
lycéennes
objectif favoriser l'engagement des
élèves et leur initiative pour une
gestion durable de l'établissement on
écoute la rectrice charline avenel
l'environnement le développement durable
est vraiment devenu
un sujet phare pourquoi parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte que l'ondé de choc
avec nos élèves est colossal des élèves
qui trie à l'école ça veut dire des
élèves qui trie dans leur famille des
familles qui change de pratiques et on
forme
on referme une jeunesse avec une onde de
choc pour les générations futures ont
terminé au lycée michael avec de gros
changements qui sont à prévoir pour les
lycéens avec cette réforme du
baccalauréat
on en parle beaucoup à grégory c'est le
gros dossier de cette rentrée exit les
premières s es et l place un parcours
beaucoup plus personnalisé qui sera mis
en place dès cette année pour les élèves
de 1re cette spécialité ou plus seront
proposés dans la quasi-totalité des
lycées du territoire en parallèle le
système d'évaluation va également
changer les élèves de 1re passeront dès
le deuxième trimestre une série
d'épreuves sur table ils ont également
un examen au troisième trimestre des
partiels lycéens qui compteront pour 30
% de la note finale du contrôle continu
à réaction c'est évidemment une très
bonne chose parce que ça évite le stress
de l'examen
ça permet d'échelonner
ça permet d'avoir une progressivité et
puis ça permet à l'ensemble du système
de ne pas être dépendant de ces quelques
jours de la fin juin donc voilà c'est
une
c'est une modalité beaucoup plus facile
est vraiment dans l'intérêt des élèves
merci à michael pour cette chronique sur
les nouveautés juste